hello and welcome to this video is a
black game again national master go
blazers okay and they'll play the
italian nowadays yeah and i can't
understand why I mean I really do you
know I didn't never played Knight f6
year I don't know this is a good idea or
not uhm Jung hmm ok I think I came when
I have 60 actually this isn't isn't all
that great if he takes takes them ha
Bishop f7 I brook ave tonight x you form
yeah that does not win the price for
being most exciting game ever
yeah the Italian really gets to be very
annoying in those boots Candace it has
very little entertainment value and I'm
not scoring at all so when I should
think about this probably maybe yeah
study some Sicilian or anything that is
a bit more has been one was a bit more
fun
yes
I mean I'm not that unhappy with this
position per se because i think i have
no problems whatsoever yeah why cannot
take here right is trapping and actually
not takes rook there is trapping
trapping is no idea so this is a
playable rules unfortunately this is
possible okay so Bishop Bishop c5 your
problem
the issue is the issue is that b5 I just
didn't play for that draw okay m-maybe
c5 you get the bishop to deform maybe if
I get to take
so
hmm
Jim Bishop d 4 9 p-7 is not greater it's
really not grade Kim probably after I
mean I'm not all that concerned here
maybe wrongly but it takes it's got work
till five actually okay and then
probably this one I was thinking would
be eight is also possible but probably
not I didn't really think about this
move
Wow house too that was very stupid I
don't know if I don't really know Luke
c1 is the easiest move ever or the game
chat now i'm blogging 86 as well gets
better and better probably a three is
better though just keep everything I
know who we should be too maybe
check
Wow
what's going on here and put the seasons
now this one could be five or what like
miracle chess probably know this one
okay check threatening whoopsie five now
so I'm getting one back probably okay
okay five picking a look a five maybe
mkay time morning check check
okay think that they have been worse
position side this game check check
40 seconds is cool I mean this point is
not that far so I'm happy to win a pause
I'm don't know what is he doing here cap
he would still use that porn g5 is kind
of weak ish chap ok we win another phone
check check
check mmm the chatham doesn't really
allow me to play for win here even
though I would love to do it early from
the situation to play for a win kappa
nervosa was in that crappy ending
tracking wanting it's a real way to do
it right I mean objectively of course
not anyway with check check check check
check check draw offer ha ha ok oh that
was a pretty awful game yeah I mean okay
of course i can draw this stuff but i
tried something and it didn't work I
mean not at all it just like nothing
ever happens yeah this c5 computer
actually likes that move I mean so I'm
doing something wrong here right I
thought it should be interesting because
it opens up my my bishop and gets to f2
so I really made the made this this was
a mistake really so you should take and
now Luke c84 look-see tuned
so the idea wasn't all that bad i mean
this was basically what i wanted to do
but i just the way I I made it to happen
was just totally wrong because I don't
know why I did not really realize he has
Roxy one and if I trade routes first
that doesn't happen and then here I'm
just I'm just offering in a in a bad
position and I should take their hair
was simply extremely annoyed by that it
is something that he that you certainly
should happen by now I'm not so sure
anymore cap cap cap Yeji for is just
wrong with the tosser gives up Ariel
Atom white is better here what no really
I can i can bring the King around on
what I mean okay I couldn't really do
anything else than shine grabbing
everything here so how was white better
a six really that is winning four Wyatt
it's okay because it comes away with the
King seems to me I cannot move my cannot
really i also don't get f6 and this is
the problem really right you know he
takes a long time to come with a king
yeah do this this takes quite a while
and usually you get your own pawns going
but i cannot i cannot move them this is
the problem here he has g5 played this
would be a relatively comfortable draw
as i can somehow get get the King out
here but I cannot and so that was an
opportunity for him but ok it's blitz
chess k ACK
okay for now he doesn't get this in he
doesn't get this son yeah and it isn't
wrong which also that is sad exactly
comfortable troll chap chap cannot do
anything at all ok guys thanks for
watching